so a whistleblower has come out a
twitter executive has come out saying
that their security is totally bad that
they're i believe he said they were
lying to shareholders and board members
and that elon musk is correct they're
withholding information on how many bots
and spam accounts they actually have and
apparently they have the information
elon musk has now tweeted about it
because uh it's looking like he's gonna
win his lawsuit now this is crazy uh i
don't know why this guy came out this
whistleblower but apparently he got
democrats and republicans on board
mentioning this so we'll get into all
that plus we've got big news from from
last night i tweeted this after we did
the show we had the surgeon general from
florida on and he was talking about
masks and vaccines and i told him i was
like you know we talked about it on the
show that youtube bans you if you say
negative things about masks dan bongino
got got suspended from youtube rand paul
got suspended from youtube
so after the show we pulled up the
misinformation policy they have removed
youtube has removed the provision saying
you can't make these claims about masks
which is funny they did it kind of
quietly and i wonder exactly when in
april they had them in place now they
don't so
it's interesting how that works isn't it
we'll talk about that plus trump is
suing the us government over uh the raid
on his house he's trying to stop the fbi
from going through all these documents
we'll get into all that before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member if you'd
like to support our work we're gonna
have an awesome members only show coming
up tonight and the first official
episode of cast castle now as the you
know show on timcast.com is up
admittedly
we got a lot of work to do uh we need to
improve the audio quality and get lens
filters and all this stuff but um you
know my my motto is always just start
doing things cass castle's been on a
quite quite a journey and the main
reason we switched it over the website
is that we wanted more time to make
something good and uh it doesn't work on
youtube but we can't make a show like
this and just hope it's free and people
watch it so we've got two episodes of
the promo episode and the first official
episode are up now at teamcast.com for
members and don't forget tales from the
inverted world smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this news and more is tyler
merritt
hey thanks for having me out man who are
you oh wow put on the spot
uh
who i am i'm a uh entrepreneur
businessman uh started off in the
military about uh 2006.
i was flying apaches
uh for our great nation over in iraq got
picked up for uh task force 160 yes flew
for special operations for the most of
my career
and my side hustle was uh was starting
this t-shirt company called nylon
apparel i started about 10 years ago
grew from my garage to about 250
hard-working red-blooded americans in
savannah georgia and we make some pretty
nice apparel if i do say so myself
right on well glad you could join us uh
should be fun we also have hannah clara
bremelo she's back yeah i'm back i'm
hannah bremel i'm a writer for
timcast.com
and i am ian crossland what's up
everybody welcome to the show
and hi i'm chris
lydia is uh recovering from surgery she
had to get a bunch of nails what did you
get like metal plates in her wrist or
something something serious yeah skating
is dangerous you got to wear your wrist
cards and your helmets and all that
stuff all right let's jump into this
first story we got this from the wall
street journal twitter's ex security
head
files whistleblower complaint on spam
and privacy issues former executive
peter zatko makes sweeping claims with
the social network platform
the complaint which is submitted to the
securities and exchange commission last
month and became public tuesday was made
by peter zatko also known as mud she's a
hacker who was uh fired earlier this
year mr zekko's submission says he had
that he uncovered extreme egregious
deficiencies by twitter in every area of
his mandate including privacy digital
and physical security platform integrity
and content moderation i'm going to jump
over to our good friend elon musk
as many of you know he's suing twitter
because he says they didn't disclose
information on bots he's he's subpoenaed
jack dorsey the former cn uh ceo
and he tweeted this give a little
whistle and it's a chimney cricket and
then underneath it he says so spam
prevalence was shared with the board but
the board chose not to disclose that to
the public
the washington post reported four people
familiar with the company's process for
spam detection who like others spoke on
the condition of anonymity to describe
sensitive internal matters told the post
that the company keeps several internal
tallies of spam and bots known as
prevalence across the service beyond the
number supplied to wall street the post
also obtained an eternal document which
was redacted to hide the numbers showing
that spam prevalence was a number shared
with the board the document was supplied
to the board at the meetings echo
attended according to two of the people
but not to wall street so does that
include the shareholders how's this
going to work the big revelation here is
that this dude
said he believes
in foreign intelligence service
agents or individuals could be at
twitter and they're not doing anything
about it that to me is probably the
biggest red flag and this probably why
in my opinion they freaked out when elon
musk was planning to buy it then some
weird algorithmic thing happened with
the right gaining tons of followers the
left losing tons of followers then elon
musk said i want the data on bots and
they didn't give it to him now we're
learning they didn't give it to him that
they had a number that was shared with
the board well actually i shouldn't say
that
maybe elon musk was given access to this
but because of the nda he wasn't allowed
to talk about it i don't know either way
it sounds like this is going to help him
win
uh which is kind of bad news because
elon winning means he doesn't buy
twitter but i don't know what do you
guys think about this uh foreign
intelligence thing i think that's the
big takeaway huh
i'm i'm one of the biggest elon musk
fans then i don't really care if that
gets me in trouble these days you're
talking about a modern-day ironman yeah
i was in ukraine not that long ago this
guy's giving away
some communication devices that totally
change and altered the way that that
country stayed uh independent you know
there's a guy who it seems like is
putting his money where his passion is
you know he puts his
he puts everything out there and and i
was very excited to have maybe one
platform i could put my money
towards that actually cared about
pushing out the truth cared about
putting
every person's
perspective out there and not moderating
not censoring not blocking people's
opinions i've been on social uh for 10
plus years starting my company off
facebook and instagram advertising in
november of this last year right before
black friday cyber monday
facebook given its infinite wisdom
decided that i needed to be banned my
company needed to be banned so i had
well i mean look at that hat dude
absolutely that's a dangerous hat and
actually you know when we broke down the
violations right you know they couldn't
really get me on anything except for my
brother posted six years ago about a
partnership we had with jeep they said
that was violating intellectual property
of jeep i mean jeep didn't complain
because i actually had paperwork and i
was working with jeep so it was in
violation but they said that i was using
it and i didn't take it down in time so
they banned my account for a year i'm
still actually blocked you can't you
couldn't search for my account you
couldn't like my account i couldn't
share my account and every single person
that liked my account seemed to be
shadow band you know it sucks when don
jr likes your page and that's a
detriment right because if there's these
bad blue check marks out there and
everyone thinks oh it's a blue check
mark that's just a famous person well
look behind the back end you know
they're classifying and category
categorizing your blue checkbook if
you're a celebrity that has positive
messages in their opinion you get
exposure if you're a celebrity a
politician that has a message that goes
against their narrative then you are
banned not necessarily officially if
they can't do it but you'll be shadow
banned and everyone sees it yeah and and
it's known but we have no transparency
there's no oversight and these social
media oligarchs they've been acting
as such they're untouchable they can do
whatever and it's it's uh despicable i
think i think your company is a really
good example of the censorship that's
overlooked these high-profile left and
establishment journalists will be like
oh when when when joe rogan got canceled
it made him bigger or whatever and and
that's what they want people to think
canceling is meanwhile your business
gets shut down and there's no big
fanfare there's no big headline
most of the people i hear from who say
they got banned are like small accounts
oh yeah no and we're talking about
millions of followers and we're talking
about
millions of dollars for a relatively
small business right i started my garage
and and now we have large accounts i
have bass pro i have cabela's i have
five six retail stores that are very you
know highly frequented in charleston and
savannah and del and and people come
from all over to our store to experience
it and that that gives us a a sense of
you know you could try to shut me down
but i'm not going away i'll find a new
platform and i was really excited about
twitter being that new platform because
i don't even have an account you asked
me earlier what's my twitter account i
don't think i have one um because i'm
kind of over social you know if i could
pull all of my marketing dollars i would
um right now they don't seem to care if
i'm spending well over a million dollars
a year with facebook and they cancel my
account rep
because of a false narrative just
because you don't like my opinions and
of all of the groups that are like me i
am probably the least noisy the least
in your face but i i do appreciate the
second amendment the first amendment and
i got banned from writing
the
first amendment on a t-shirt and it was
told to me that that was against
facebook's policies they were like yeah
first amendment you know the rights that
shall not can't have people learning
about that
but i pushed out an email to our one
million plus you know active email
accounts and we will sell a ton of
shirts and i will get a way around it
it's just very sad that i can't promote
first amendment second amendments you
take those away
and there's no stopping a government i
had an idea for a tv show we talked
about once i think was like on the
members podcast where it's this
post-apocalyptic future
and there's like one city left
and uh no one understands how the world
ended but like the world ended and then
like people came together and built a
city and they're rebuilding and it's
like sometime around 2077 or you know 20
80 or whatever just history just dead
stops and then humanity's just gone from
the planet cities are in ruin and decay
and then the idea for this was
you know the people in the city
eventually encounter strange beings i
think are aliens they go to war then
turns out oh the aliens are actually
people and the world didn't end what
happened was
as techno technology advanced more and
more information went into the metaverse
then eventually people just went into
the metaverse and they live their lives
there now and there's very little work
that has to be done because they're not
really moving their bodies they don't
need that much caloric energy and so
there's only certain scouts that go out
to replenish the system i i we talked
about that and i got that idea because
you know i was thinking of how social
media works how these how these like
social networks are banning people
and then uh just just the this past
weekend i was at an antique store and we
were looking at all these books
this guy had a bunch of crazy we had
books from the civil war we got the
photographic collection uh photographic
history of the civil war crazy from
1911. so there's actual photos of like
the 1860s
it's nuts that's not going to exist in
the future
the way it's going with social media and
why it's so important that someone like
you know elon pushed back i don't think
he cares anymore i don't i think he's
trying to get away from the whole thing
but the reason why social media
censorship is so dangerous
if the world ended right now
the overwhelming majority of information
would be gone like world ending i mean
if let's say the power went out in every
major city
you would not be able to access our
website timcast.com i mean the
information exists on the hardware some
somewhere where's the data center who
knows how you're going to look up the
ips i don't know computers shut down so
if
you know 100 years ago there's a
collapse society breaks down you walk
into a library you find all the books
still sitting there hopefully not
damaged but these books could be all
over the place you could find the
history and be like wow look at this
in the future it's going to be very
different
if there is a major collapse catastrophe
like that overnight no one is going to
know where any of this information is
and if you don't have electricity or a
means to decode the the data off the
hard drives
you know hunt there could be a a
solar flare or a great war
and let's say it's a hundred year 150
years and people are like looking at
these mainframes going the summation of
human knowledge exists on these machines
it could teach us so much about the
world and how to survive but we can't
get access to it because we lost that
technology when the collapse happened no
books no reading nothing you can
preserve maybe you'll get lucky and
someone will figure it out anyway i
bring that up because like the way it's
going with censorship
that idea i had for a show it's like the
reason there was a last city because
those are the people who weren't allowed
in these are these are the descendants
of the people who were banned from the
metaverse and had to go and build their
own economy somewhere else
so what i see happening with censorship
you're going to have people who get
banned and they will find a way to
engage in commerce
my dystopian future vision of it is
a city of people living you know because
their descendants are forced to work and
live in this alternate space and then
everyone else lives in the virtual
reality but i kind of think that's a
that's one direction we're going in
maybe it won't be that bad um the
reality of these things is these
predictions typically don't pan out
because within 20 years technology will
have changed so much my prediction will
make no sense
but there you go well have you ever seen
the movie idiocracy yes it's one of my
favorite it actually kind of starts to
prove that fact that you have
smartphones and dumb people
and we're not making or doing a service
to our young people or to the
individuals who just like that that easy
button we're making it easier and easier
and easier for society and we're telling
them that when you
fail it's not your fault when you fail
it you need to blame everything
elsewhere you know that that idea of
ownership the idea of you know wanting
to go and read through an encyclopedia
to find an answer but if i can't find it
on the first page of google you know
that's what sometimes i'll talk to my
younger employees like hey sir you told
me to go and research something so i
went on google and i searched and
nothing came up like wow
and then you came directly back to me
that's very sad and but it's it's
exactly what you probably have seen a
lot in the
say younger generation i grew up with no
phone than a flip phone and now i have a
phone but i despise it if i can get away
from this thing and i can get back into
reading books and engaging in
conversation because that's where real
knowledge comes from that's what's it's
debate you know it's not reading what
someone else posted on google
right that wikipedia where anyone can
alter it and people come to me with
these facts about masks about
vaccines it's funny how when things
become mainstream everyone all of a
sudden becomes a subject matter expert
like that because it's on the front page
of google might do 100 yeah everything
got shut down uh for covert right i
became a non-essential company so my
company with 250 people was forced to
shut down and die that's closing company
yeah
not clothes are essential right and i
had black rifle coffee was my favorite
coffee free coffee to all first
responders but uh you know our coffee
shops were shut down our retail stores
were shut down our manufacturing plant
what state
georgia wow really yeah yeah and there
was definitely some internal politics
going on there that uh you know it
caused that but uh
i'd say that if i didn't switch and to
start distributing these cloth masks
that i knew were not effective in any
way shape or form you know i'm an
engineer i like making and building
things we made our own n95 masks you
know ones that actually worked that were
made here in the united states but
there's no way we were getting any type
of large contracts you know they were
going to 3am they're going to honeymoon
so that they could take these billion
dollar contracts by the way they still
haven't produced these masks you know
500 plus million mass they're you know
were given billion dollar contracts they
didn't have to be produced for 18 months
you know i bid on them and said that i
could do it with my partners at
gulfstream my partners that were these
nasa-based engineering firms that had
proven that our science worked and that
it was cheaper better faster made in the
us but no one wanted to hear it and
that's where you know that that science
is overruled by political science you
know the math and the numbers and the
engineering is no longer a discussion so
i could go on television and and talk
about
things based on my knowledge of science
and engineering and be challenged by
some youtube
dummy who just googled fauci's last
periodical of nonsense and and said you
know what you're wrong and you're
against the science and you just want to
promote all these negative things and
therefore you are a bad human and and
you can't even engage in conversation
let's jump to this next story
what i have before you my friends is uh
youtube's covered misinformation policy
the funny thing about this is unlike you
know the the most of the code stuff's
over like the mandates are mostly over
the us still require vaccines for entry
but they don't actually check so it's
actually the airlines who are requiring
and then some people here's a funny
thing tons of people everybody who
travels knows this
they're like you don't fly to the united
states anymore you fly to tijuana and
then walk in
just walk in they don't check they don't
care it's the weirdest gap in security
and policy or whatever but anyway here's
the point
youtube's medical misinformation policy
when you scroll down to prevention
misinformation doesn't mention anything
about masks in fact i will do this in
real time ctrl f and we'll type in
m-a-s-k nothing
the word mask does not appear in
youtube's misinformation policy anymore
so i tweeted this youtube updated its
policies to no longer ban claims that
masks do not play a role in preventing
the spread of covet essentially you are
now allowed to claim masks don't work
so we can see
initially it used to say this
claims that masks do not play a role in
preventing the contraction or
transmission of covet 19 you are not
allowed to say that
youtube removed that and uh
i'm assuming you can now say it
here's what they say i'll let you say it
first because i got all kinds of
censorship oh no
period of time in my life i'm good the
it says that the um the google uh
misinformation policy youtube's policies
on cover 19 are subject to change in
response to changes to global or local
health authorities guidance in the virus
there may be a delay between new lha and
who guidance and policy updates given
the frequency with which his guidance
changes and our policies may not cover
all lha and who guidance related to
covet you know this is this is a serious
problem
that
scientists
have been saying this very thing
and youtube was banning them rand paul
came out dude's a doctor
they just they gave him a strike on
youtube for bringing this up
if a doctor can't even talk about it
which doctor can
youtube has arbitrary arbitrarily chosen
the world health organization as their
end-all be-all for what is true and
correct
this is extremely dangerous
because the world health organization is
a political entity not a medical one it
is a political international entity not
a medical body it is not like an
academic group of doctors at a
university doing clinical trials it is a
political institution and youtube's like
they'll be the experts do you think
that's because they feel like they are
obligated to listen to a global
authority because they view themselves
as a global platform even though it's
based in the us i think for for uh
youtube it's the easy way out yeah the
world health organization they have
their their pinky they sound good enough
no no they actually work with a bunch of
countries therefore it's easier to use
them as a standard so that we don't get
in trouble with other countries so how
do we pick our arbitrators for other
fact checking you know you had the was
it the washington post we're not
watching for new york times and other
periodicals that were being sent
articles to see if it was political
misinformation if it was scientific
misinformation it didn't have to just be
about masks but either you're going to
have complete censorship or you have no
censorship and the complete censorship
needs a lot of oversight and we're not
there and that's the idea that you're
not going to have a platform that's
perfect you know there's things that we
can all agree on that exploitation of
children violence you know extremism in
some sort of way of like
calls for violence basically calls for
violence yeah those are generally
accepted no-no's it's when we get into
these gray areas that you you take a
hard-line stance and you ruin businesses
you ruin people's lives the the problem
is
some people argue for free speech
absolutism meaning you they they argue
you could you know call for violence
because you didn't actually do anything
and i get it
if the idea is you know we don't allow a
speech that calls for violence because
that's a crime
well that's not an argument because then
all that has to happen is they decide
another kind of speech is a crime
okay well now you know insulting someone
organizing their pronouns is assault or
violence and thus now they can say well
that's not free speech you're committing
a crime right so there is there is an
issue in at what point does speech
become illegal and can it
and a question of shouldn't it just be
on you to defend yourself
i i would think so but we we have seen
that it becomes a safe haven you know a
place where people can congregate and
start creating organizations and a
movement of violence and extremism and i
i think you know it's very similar and
has some connotations to
afghanistan and people had an argument
of we don't need to be there there's no
uh
objective for us but it allowed for a
safe haven of horrible individuals to
congregate plan and execute atrocious
acts you know in my opinion you need to
have some oversight but it's not
living there 24 7 it's pinpoint
action taken towards those individuals i
don't i don't think there's
a solution at all uh so they want to
censor people because
you know people are offensive or
whatever
we start we we all agree like hey don't
incite violence don't tell people to
commit violence don't tell them how to
commit violence we agree that's a bad
thing the issue though is now from that
point they've moved on to the next point
stochastic terrorism well now you're
saying things that will infer the idea
or convince someone to go do something
well that's calling for violence that's
where they're at now and they and they
will eventually ban that i'm not
entirely sure they can i'm saying their
goal is to get that kind of speech
banned where if you said something like
we should shut that school down because
of the horrible things they do they say
hey we know what you're getting at it's
uh won't someone rid me of this
meddlesome priest thing and that's what
they're trying to argue now because
people like james lindsey and libs of
tiktok have been criticizing these these
uh hospitals that have been doing you
know surgery on these kids they're
saying oh that's stochastic terrorism
and their goal is to rally people to to
eventually go and do something it's like
there's no line you can keep ramping it
up until eventually you've banned all
species just because you're afraid
doesn't mean that i made you afraid like
just because someone's in terror doesn't
mean that someone else committed a
terroristic act terror is a very
well i don't know i think it's very
hardcore i mean if you're you're making
people fear for their life without other
than words in the united states it's an
imminent threat of violence not just
threats of violence not like hey go
something something it's when you give a
date and a time and a place that creates
an imminent threat and that is illegal
in the united states you're allowed to
say like hey go
fill in the blank not i'm not talking
about youtube from talking about
american civil liberties uh but you
cannot call for imminent threats of
violence i think that social networks
that are based in the united states and
around the united states should follow
american law personally that's what
mines does oh they follow the world
health organization instead
uh then i think we should take the keys
away
um and maybe free up the space a little
bit because private companies should not
be getting in the way of the country
that help them create themselves
and individuals who find themselves
wronged in every way shape or form and
there's settings out there you can make
yourself private you can ban everyone
from being on your page you can just get
off of social you know that's one of
those things where i'd like to tell
people if it's really causing you this
much anxiety and this much heartache one
it might be you two you have options to
just turn it off
it's it's it's not that big of a deal
but when we start infringing upon
everyone else's rights just to make you
happy
that's where i draw a line you know just
get off of social if it's the fact that
people aren't adjusting by the right
pronouns if people aren't addressing you
by the right
fill in the blank and now you're on a
rampage and now it's your social justice
warrior and i have to placate to that
and i don't want to and that's really
what it boils down to is you you just do
you let me do me and i think if we could
ever get back to that point you know we
would be a much happier society but
right now we just hone in on the
negatives we try to
impose our opinions on other people as
opposed to saying hey you know we have a
difference of opinion that's fine that's
why i like to
fight overseas against terrorists who
don't allow you to have a different
opinion you talk about all the bad
things here go to those other countries
where you get stoned to death
what about intercourse with someone else
what about the terrorists that are here
trying to stop you from being able to
say whatever say what you want and have
an opinion and the ones who are running
big companies and defending those people
those are domestic terrorists in my
humble opinion hopefully that's going to
be kicked off who are you talking about
like when you know blm or anything will
show up and throw a brick through your
window because you said not to yeah i
think they are domestic terrorists
people that will destroy property and
threaten life for a social movement i
think are would i would consider them
terrorism consider george washington a
terrorist king george did at the time
yeah there was a meme going around where
um
these people are posting like trump
should remember you know this is what
they do to traders and it was a guy
being hanged the funny thing though is i
was like it was redcoats hanging a
minute man a con or not a mini map a
continental army you know you know blue
coat and then i was just like
this the the treason you're showing was
against the crown like it was the
americans being like yo we don't believe
in monarchy and so they said that's
treason and these people are sharing
that as if like it's a good thing to
uphold because it shows that fighting
oppression
is no longer the mainstream it's now
everyone wants to be subjugated they
want to be told what to do they want to
be told you know that that everything
that's not good with you everything
that's gone wrong in your life it's not
you it's not your lack of effort it's
not your
uh
work effort
it's everyone else's and that we need to
take things and give to
this group um yeah i i think that's a
slippery slope that we're headed just
out of curiosity were you ever on any
alternative platforms like mines or gab
or don't even know what those are
they're just alternatives to i don't
know
any social media platform or twitter no
i'm probably the world's worst on uh
getting on social and and trying to stay
engaged i do try to
um you know connect with my my kids try
to connect with my uh fan base but uh
you know this is one of those things
that's it's kind of foreign to me you
know i'm a guy who'd rather be out in
the woods and be completely disconnected
from the world let's uh let me pull up
this tweet here and we'll just we'll
spend some time ragging on dr fauci you
know he's leaving
and i'm quite disappointed because this
means i won't be able to do the voice
rolls for freedom tunes anymore but uh
the truth is sheamus hasn't been calling
that's right sheamus of freedom tunes he
hasn't called me to do a voice of fouchy
even with the big fouchy news i get it
sheamus
but i know what you're here for
ian miles chong tweeted fauci has the
fouchy devotional candle on his
bookshelves you couldn't make this up
here's a picture of fauchi
here's the bookshelf behind him and
right here you can see it that's the
fouchy devotional candle it is an image
of fouchy as like i think jesus is that
it let me see yeah
that's what those devotional candles are
they're usually the virgin mary
in south america all right fouchy out of
the virgin has a devotional candle of
himself depicting himself as as jesus is
that what it is
of the savior
how many would you buy
no just one i don't know would you light
it
yeah
i said this yesterday but like i kept
saying he didn't want to retire because
out of vanity like he retiring means
that you're old and that you're like you
can no longer work and that's why his
announcement is very much like you know
i'm just stepping down to continue to
work even though he's like 81. i you
know maybe someone got this candle for
him as like a gag gift they were like
this is so funny or a candle i could
definitely see doing that to someone i
know if they were suddenly turned into a
devotional candle but to know that
you're gonna have it in the background
of your interview to me it's just like
isn't this this is this is a form of
narcissism right you see yourself as a
savior and incompetence i think it's
like nice mix between the two because
you're a doctor but have uh
you know no ability to discern science
from political science yeah i think
you're
an absolute clown that's perfect i think
it was like it's a stereotype for
doctors right to have a god complex and
like the entire american media handed
this to vouching we're like no we really
could not make it through this pandemic
without you sir and i think it's gone to
his head so here check check this out
ian miles chung posted the photo
this is what's behind him is that
who is the supposed i was fouchy i would
definitely put that behind me yeah
that's hilarious i wouldn't buy it i
don't think but if people shifted to you
yeah people sent me stuff to our p.o box
for a while and one of them was a shirt
with my face on it i've worn it on the
show i think it's freaking hilarious
it's one of my favorite shirts i would i
didn't go out and make it to show
everyone like hey look how great i am
but i'm sure people are sending him tons
of stuff uh merchandise about him and
he's just like rolling with it if anyone
made him a devotional candle i would buy
it and bring it
i pointed this out because you know
before the show we were ragging on it
and then i was like to be fair someone
sent a golden bust of my face to us and
it's like sitting on a table downstairs
and i'm like
i
i don't know i like it came in a box
someone else opened the box someone else
put it there and now there's like this
bronze statue of me and it's like weird
i had a headshot that we use for um uh
one of our cass castle uh shows and it
was out in the living room for like a
month it was just on the table and i was
like yeah everyone get a taste like feel
it for like three weeks and then it
started to feel really weird so i took
it and put it in my closet you hung it
up in your room yeah i put it behind
some things in a on a shelf are you
talking about the painting no i want to
display that that thing's hot no it's
just a headshot from my college days
from like my los angeles
uh ian has a miniature version of
himself on the table right now yeah so
this is another example of it this is
right here this is ian crossland
bobblehead someone made thank you so
much i didn't make it but someone sent
it to me and it would almost be like an
insult not to display it at that point
see that's that's the thing right i
remember when uh the the photo went
viral of fouchy in his office he's got a
painting of himself
and then everybody was like he's got he
works under a painting of himself and
then we had someone on the show and they
were just like his daughter probably
painted it for him and then i was like
oh that's a good point see that's why he
would put it up with the candle it
totally could just be a gift right
someone was like this is hilarious i
will get this for you but
i don't know i guess he has just like
really lost my uh respect and any of my
you respected him no i never respect he
never earned my respect i guess what i
should say uh it's hard really not to
see this as
him like it's hard to imagine that he
doesn't look at that every day and think
like i am really saving america you know
what i mean like did you see the money
that's the long flowing hairs right you
guys would laugh at yourself with your
busts and your t-shirts and like you're
humble so there's there's an element to
it but like i don't know if that's how
fat she views this candle did you see
the video clip of him i did a i did a
great twitter troll he was quoted as
saying that he was like inspiring people
it was the fouchy effect and that he in
this time of of untruth he represented
truth and science something like that
yeah so i quoted it directly
and then under the tweet was like oops
can't forget the video and then i was
like we're gonna separate the men from
the boys here and see who actually read
the twitter thread and understood it was
a quote or who just blindly was like
i can't believe tim paul said this about
himself but then jack bessok was on that
night and he was like oh i didn't click
through oh the video like he totally got
it afterwards but oh i didn't know jack
fell for it one of the boys i mean
that's what i wrote i'm saying somebody
can clip it i guess but uh yeah i
remember you doing that i mean i just
think that like anthony fauci is
an arrogant person and so if it were
someone who had humility i would laugh
this candle but it is like hard not to
be like come on guy you couldn't clear
your bookshelf at all i i i'm tasked
with saving people's lives and he's a
bit of a megalomaniac i think at the
very least that's
goes without saying a bit of one the way
he talks about himself as a savior is a
little crazy look at look at these
photos okay this guy abhi cole he's got
the devotional fouchy candle this guy
this lady julie pfeiffer she's got one
here's another fouchy a devotional
candle with a mask next to it and like
of course it's freaking insane too if
they
if there is anything that makes me want
to just
buy a van and go live down by the river
and never think of any of this political
stuff again it is this
these these people are serious guess
what they vote
yeah well i've seen these devotional
candles for like snoop dogg and martha
stewart and some other people this
t-shirt company
in dallas that he's like sold them too
it's just like in our culture with the
weird adoration for dr anthony fauci
when they tried to like make him like a
like
pop cultural influence like it it's not
good i think hardwood was like we lost
ruth bader ginsburg and so we needed
some other
like older new yorker that we all were
obsessed with and like they just
couldn't make anthony fouchy work
i don't know it just creeps remember
cuomo sexual
oh yeah that was what is wrong wrong
with these people cultists
yeah all around man zilinski they
worship
the president of the united states they
worship him when he gets the job like
all of a sudden now he's something and
worship is a great word for it like it
has to be more than just like oh i
respect your work or he's got some good
points it's like weird devotion say what
they say do not question them like that
is these these are the icons that
they're trying to prop up for themselves
which is very strange it's creepy it's
creepy it's a creepy bunch of people in
a cult and they're all voting so you
better go out and tell all your friends
to go vote does nine life sell
devotional candles we've not got into
that market i think i might skip that
one
i mean unless i can use your face as a
model i feel like you're more jesusy
with that flowy
you have all the right adjectives you
just gave it out yeah it's all you
anyone that wants to make t-shirts with
my face on it they're all you make as
much money off them as you want to make
tens of dollars
you know the cult's getting bigger
um or maybe it's not i don't know what
do you guys think do you think i i feel
like you know liz cheney she's out we
got a primary tonight i think louder not
bigger
i think that sometimes with cults like
when they become stressed in some way
the people who are really devoted double
down and the people who are like on the
outside already sort of be like i don't
know if i want to leave and they back
out even now like i got employees that
work for me especially in leadership we
don't always see the same
you know
same eye
and i know people voted for this and
whenever they're complaining about the
gas prices or not being able to hire
people or all of these things that you
voted for i kindly remind them like
you did this like this is your fault and
they did exactly what they said they're
gonna do you know we had a previous
president said i'm going to build a wall
reduce energy prices do this do that
like he had a playbook and he went and
executed on it not everything went
according to plan not everything went as
stated but that was his intention and he
went to work day one day one
they destroyed energy prices and energy
is tied to absolutely everything that we
have to deal with and transportation and
goods and you know talk about inflation
it was day one how do we create this
socialist society without going through
congress and they did it you want 15 an
hour no problem because everything cost
15 now so i got to pay someone who was
being paid 10 bucks to catch a t-shirt
at the end of the dryer is now being
paid 15 now that manager who was 15 is
now 20 and now everyone else is 25 and
guess what you only want to spend so
much on a usa made t-shirt right
but there is no incentive to buy things
in the u.s and there's no disincentive
to import stuff from china so when i
sell people that my competitors are
using slave cotton like literally slave
cotton and they're illegally putting
into their garments and then they're
selling it at a price point i can't
match because i don't have any slaves in
georgia that's hundreds of years ago and
freaking wrong well i gotta i gotta be
honest i'm pretty sure like this shirt
is probably like bangladesh or something
i can tell you that my stuff's not i
could tell you that there's shirts
instead but there's a there's a price
point associated right so i want cheap
tasks good and we're all done here in
the united states well that's not a
thing you can put your money where your
mouth is you can vote with your dollars
and that's what i've been trying to tell
people is that when you're sitting up on
stage and you're talking about all of
these values that you
are concerned about you know your social
justice warriors out there then why are
your products that you're wearing
literally made by slaves
why are the things that you're
purchasing going to regimes that hate us
and want to destroy us these are regimes
like the chinese communist government
not chinese people i have lots of
chinese friends so don't confuse the two
right the six percent ruling class of
china that rules with an iron fist that
has zero regard for human rights that
has zero regard for anything other than
world domination and i i don't care what
anyone else has to say that is what they
want you know this is an organization
that has said
recently that they've won the war
without firing a shot because they look
at economic warfare's warfare they look
at biological warfare as warfare so if
kovid was not the perfect test run of
biological warfare and i'm not a
conspiracy theorist i'm just saying it
was a absolute biological agent that
wreaked havoc on the world except for
one country which has seemed to benefit
very very much so
you know we are living
blindly and we're putting our money and
we're voting
with our dollars towards organizations
that support china towards organizations
that support slavery and anyone who
wants to talk about that gets censored i
made a usa made shirt uh video today
talking about are cotton made in the u.s
are cutting and sewing me in the us are
printing in the u.s when now people are
out there saying hey you know you can't
make things the u.s like i can do it i'm
a freaking aviator i have zero knowledge
in textile manufacturing the last 10
years we figured it out right we're
americans we can do this better cheaper
faster but no one cares so when the
president of the united states goes on
television and says during the state of
the union we're going to encourage and
make sure that everything's made in the
u.s not one piece of legislation is to
stop any type of imports of textile
goods that can be made here especially
from china not one piece of legislation
that gives credits towards r d research
and development for manufacturing
capabilities like cars right so i can't
get any type of credits for my employees
i hire i can't get any credit for the r
d that i do and i do a lot of r d to be
able to try to compete with china i have
to be more efficient
none of that if i was a tech company i
get lots of rd credits i paid no taxes
if i just took all my manufacturing and
i brought it overseas i'd make so much
more profit it's incredible and
apparently no one would care so until
the united states they're voting with
their dollars you know understand that
that money goes to an organization that
most likely
influences politics yeah we're just
going to keep it's simple doing more the
same china
can't
the chinese countries party can't donate
directly to a politician to support them
but they can hire people to do things
who they know will support certain
politics thus giving more economic power
to people who will destroy this country
so we have no insight into china because
they have locked it down you can't
influence their politicians you'll go to
jail forever in that country do they
have politicians i just have party
members they do have party members but
you you're not influencing them you know
big brother is a thing you know we are
social your facial recognition you can't
leave cities without social credits i
mean it is 1984 today and these
organizations
china specifically the communist party
there's nothing that stops them from
espionage right coming here and learning
everything they can and bring it back to
their country i have intellectual
property that i sent to china to make
it's i have a hoodie that holds your
beer hands-free right so i've got two
patents one on an n95 mast so you can
breathe without dying it actually works
um sorry fda said i can't say that
according to all of my fda tests it
works better than 3ms but i'm no longer
allowed to sell it because there's no
more euas and i just had to eat millions
of dollars really oh yeah absolutely wow
that's a whole different story but i
like science i like engineering so i
made this patented product where you can
hold your beer hands-free on your hoodie
right not as like a socket or something
it's a cool pocket yes you kind of
dumbed down my patent but yes it's a
pocket in your in your hoodie it's an
engineering engineered compartment thank
you so much a kangaroo pouch if you will
um but i sent it to china with the tech
pack to have them manufacture this is
eight
years ago right uh and they gave it to
my competitors and started selling
everyone else and um they told me that
they don't believe intellectual property
it's it's trade secrets if it was if you
can't own an idea man there's no there's
no patents there they consider it trade
secrets so once the secret is known it
can be shared with absolutely everyone
as long as they can make money they will
so there is no respect for intellectual
property um there is no respect for
human life and this is an organization
that is not our friend and they threaten
to shoot down our
our uh what vice president secretary
defense sex state who is it they were
going to show
that
there we go speaker of the house so they
want to shoot down a sitting member of
uh congress and uh you know our response
is please don't do that you know we are
a very weak country right now in my
opinion because we have weak leadership
and um
until that changes you know i i don't
see us
improving the midterms are coming up i'm
uh i'm pretty optimistic
i'm not super optimistic about the
leadership we're going to end up with
mcconnell and you know kevin mccarthy so
nothing will really get done but you'll
have some good people in there doing
some good stuff it's not all bad right
yeah i think what we saw when you had uh
you know trump come to power you had a
change in politics that shook things up
you know it was a time when everyone was
tired with the status quo and they they
didn't want more of the same i think
people on both sides are starting to see
that again you know that going back to
traditional politicians you get more of
the same we actually
reversed course so fast day one
and to see the state of the economy
right now and to see the state of
affairs you know from a world stage
having traveled a lot into the eastern
european countries uh as of late you
know we are a joke um yeah we're a
laughing stock what do you think about
ron de santos
i would be very excited for a uh
desantis ticket uh if
our
current
um
i guess if the donald were in my opinion
to support and endorse that person and
push the trump supporters
towards him i think that we actually
would have a shot you know conservatives
right i'll identify as a conservative
you know no other pronouns just
conservative and that's not a negative
thing it just means i'm of a fiscal
conservative and social libertarian i
could care what you do with your
ding-a-ling just don't talk to my
children about it that's my job
would you prefer trump or would you
prefer to santa's like if desantis
because i think he has
an opportunity to win because i think
there's more than this is nothing to do
with the donald right now i've gone to
mar-a-lago i've met him a few times i've
he's helped me with getting my friend
eddie gallagher out of prison you know i
i have no no ill will towards uh former
president united states
what i do have is uh it will towards not
taking a uh a stance towards what's the
what's the most likely course of action
if he were to run you're gonna have a
lot of individuals never trumpers that
rally their base to vote against him
just because it's him and that's the
unfortunate truth is that they'll get
more people that would have voted
conservative to not vote conservative
just because they don't like the orange
man
there uh
there is a concerted effort in media
right now to go after tennis that way
you know they're actually trying to say
that he's worse than trump because they
have to they have to and it's crazy
because they already said trump was you
know literally worse than hitler and i'm
not entirely sure what they're
complaining about with a scientist but
they just have to say something
otherwise he'll win
that that's their play is they they just
say things louder and louder and louder
and you know my godfather i love having
a conversation with him i used to break
as a thesaurus is bill buckley jr he
kind of
started the modern conservative movement
and you know he would always tell me
that
you'll never win an argument with an
idiot they'll just talk louder and
that's what i find when i when i try to
engage into a political discussion with
someone who is so far left or honestly
right it really doesn't matter when you
have extremisms on both parties and you
can't
um find a way to have a conversation
without raising your voice because we
have a difference of opinion on
women's reproductive rights about the
second amendment about that's all the
first amendment but it's i've seen it on
both sides too i've seen people go
extremely far
right and angry because i don't agree
with something to do with women's
reproductive rights right which i'm not
even going to get into that because it's
i just don't feel like it's a topic of
conversation where you can win it's just
a difference of opinion some people are
extremely religious some people are not
and i think that we've degraded
our our morals in this country and i
think that it's become the popular thing
not to go to church i think it's the
popular thing not to
have um
what i would consider old school
morals right that are usually
faith-based because it's not the cool
thing to do anymore and actually stalin
said it best that they'll never win a
war in the united states because of our
moral convictions because of the fact
that you know we believe in in our
country and what it's founded by and
that you can't break that spirit uh
and i think slowly but surely we've
eroded the morals of this country and
and when i say morals i mean doing the
right thing when no one else is looking
well let's talk about the one person
who's done the right thing
liz cheney
no i'm kidding uh we have the story of
yahoo news new poll indicates a liz
cheney presidential run would hurt biden
more than trump it can be uh simply
shown in this chart in this graph right
here if liz cheney were to run as an
independent democrats would vote for her
helping donald trump win
and based on this polling they're
actually saying right now and this is
another i don't necessarily believe all
this they're saying right now based on
their polling data joe biden would beat
donald trump in an election if it was
held today or at least at the time of
this this poll
support for joe biden 46 percent trump's
42
but if liz cheney runs an independent
joe biden 32 cheney 11 trump 40. i would
i'd be very interested to know what the
poll would say if a desantis were to run
endorsed by trump
and those two i think it would be a
landslide i think he would um
he would do very well people need to
understand too landslides it doesn't
mean like 80 of the general public votes
for the candidate it means like 55
percent does and this results in a
massive swing in the electoral college
you end up with all the states there's a
thing you know people were saying that
trump won in the landslide against
hillary he won three states that got him
over and it was by 88 000 votes so
that's not a landslide but industrial
college it came out to like a you know
decent number of electoral votes that he
ended up winning but the electoral votes
are shifting new york lost two and
florida gained two you know california i
think lost one too right what yeah when
you have these policies that cause a
mass exodus of intellectual individuals
you know they're going to find refuge
they are refugees that's why i try to
tell people when they come from my home
state of connecticut to georgia or to
florida like you are not a prophet
please don't come here with the politics
that i left maybe you are a refugee so
they they they do and it's worse than
that they bring other people with them
i i haven't really been seeing that in
the southeast i've been seeing
individuals coming there and acting as
refugees saying hey we are here because
where i left is not good and it's
getting worse because what you guys have
going on in georgia and in florida is
better than where i left and i don't
want to mess it up elon musk was in
california
people who live in california 2-1 are
democrats
elon musk moves to texas and opens the
gigafactory a lot of these employees i'm
assuming maybe i'm wrong i'm assuming he
didn't fire everybody in california
right probably transferred a bunch of
them
that's a bunch of california
progressives being moved into austin
so i do think there are more refugees
than there are people transferring
because of
work policy
but depending on the size of the
industry and
of the individual they might bring you
know for every one high net worth
individual who's like hey i believe in
liberty and freedom they might bring 10
woke employees with them
att moved to dallas the dallas area i
think in
could be wrong on that and they were
based in california pre before that so
they also transferred their employees
out there i mean i think i'm sure some
had the option to leave the company stay
a lot came to dallas it really blew up a
couple of the suburbs in the dallas area
and this is prior to trump being elected
i mean the shift towards pro-business
states has been going on for a long time
it wasn't just coveted in politics that
started a
mass migration of people with maybe not
the political leanings of the states
they were ultimately ending up in i
think kova just made it much more of a
intentional choice for some people there
was much more of an examination of the
life you were living because you were
suddenly stuck at home having to
reconsider what you really wanted well
look at the flexibility that people were
able to gain once we realized that you
could work virtually right so
individuals who were working for
companies that could now work at home
chose to not live in a
degrading society right meaning the the
crime is up the
bang for your buck is down and it only
seems to be getting worse those
individuals are the ones that i see
leaving in mass exodus they're not
leaving because their business
massive company moved so they had to
move with it they're moving because they
have the freedom and flexibility to
choose to not live in new york city to
choose to not live in l.a and they've
decided um
that that's not for them anymore that
they don't want to live in fear of
walking down the street and getting
mugged and raped and murdered
because there's there's lawlessness in
l.a it's like zombieland my
manufacturing partners are out there and
when i go out there it's just gotten
worse and worse and worse it's it's
straight up zombieland yeah i remember
for a while maine offered this program
or if you were a remote worker you'd
come live in maine and get you know i
don't remember money towards a house or
a tax credit or something like that
maine has an aging population and they
don't have a ton of industry so they
really do want remote workers to come in
and repopulate have kids have young
families obviously maine is beautiful
lots of outdoor stuff there is a reason
you would want to be there it's just not
possible if you can't work there
and this was way before covet i mean
this was happening again i think it was
like 2010
but at the time there were not as many
remote positions as there are now i
think that we'll continue to see states
with low birth rate or older populations
trying to incentivize remote workers to
come out because again
if you can work
have a steady job and work wherever you
want you are much more likely to choose
a place that's reflective both of your
political or ideological values but also
of a lifestyle that you want to live
delaware figured it out
delaware figured a lot of it out
there's a lot of states that drive
business away and it's really
interesting how the economics of this
work if you're an ice cream shop
you register your business in the state
because you're like in the state but if
you do national level business
why would you not be in delaware
that the tax that the laws the
restrictions the taxes in every state
are are cumbersome so this is why every
corporation not literally every but like
most of them will just open up in
delaware i think nevada is another one
and wyoming is good too but but now even
california was leading the charge of how
to ruin their online business and tax
income because right now because of
recent laws in the last few years uh
wayfarer versus
north dakota oh yeah yeah and there was
that title title nine or whatever that
thing was so sales tax is now collected
in all 50 states once you hit nexus
threshold right so california is
actually one of my largest states right
we send millions of dollars of product
there
sales tax fine i collect sales tax i
give it to you as of lately now
california's saying actually we want a
percentage of our income tax
as well so i'm a georgia resident i pay
georgia state income tax at seven
percent which is still higher than zero
which is florida right i'm sure i could
probably find ways around it and i don't
feel like going to irs jail or getting
shot by that dude in the wheelchair um
for whatever reason you saw the video
irs tactical training i don't even know
why they have guns but okay so
i
have been told now i'm expected
according to california to pay taxes as
if i was a california resident because i
in their mind i'm a resident i have no
physical property i've never go to the
state for more than 24 hours because i
hate it not because the
beautiful scenery just no offense the
people they're insane so well i mean the
the the climate's bad too like they're
in a drought it's like not going all the
political environment the uh discussions
the uh focus of their attention on what
i consider silly things it's i'm not a
big fan and i definitely don't want to
pay 17 still stacks to a state that i
don't physically go to like it's i'm
it's my company and they're saying all
your revenue yes yeah that apportionment
of it goes gets taxed at 17
so obviously i politely declined and
said that according to federal laws is
this and that'll be another supreme
court
ruling to see if we now as
internet-based companies have to start
paying these insane taxes so i don't
even know how that would work so i pay
17 tax to california and 12 to new york
and all this i would have
zero right dollars left over and i don't
understand how people don't get business
right i started my garage i sold my car
to buy my first machine i sold my house
to buy another machine by the way when
you're deploying a bunch no notice and
you have a pregnant wife with two kids
and a great danes and you move them into
apartment that does not they don't like
it they don't like that but you know
it's a sacrifice right so we continue to
sacrifice and put everything all in and
now i'm at a point where the level of
taxes that i pay
as compared to amazon you know i pay
tens millions of dollars more than
amazon has and that that is absolutely
ludicrous
but it's obvious why you will own
nothing and you will be happy
i think that is the plan um i will
always be happy and i think that
happiness is is on you we don't we don't
do any business with california in any
possible way to strict company policy
california is state non-grata for us
whatever however it would actually be
stated and we've had people who hit us
up and like hey we'd love to work with
you or like we want to submit an article
or we're looking for work and i'm just
like as long as you're in california
there's not a conversation to be had and
it's and and to put it simply california
has laws in order to just not run a file
we just do not do any operations in any
capacity with anyone in the state of
california oh no i'm being sued right
now by a blind man in new york and
another person in california who's
saying that my website is not blind
accessible which it is by the way for
full dis you know
if anyone who's listening this and
happens to not be able to see you can
absolutely go to nineteen
lineapparel.com and you will talk to you
just as it's supposed to but anyone can
sue anyone from those states and they're
very sue
um not happy but i guess they they
encourage it so i will spend tens of
thousands of dollars on these frivolous
lawsuits in california and in new york
and i won't get a change of venue to
georgia because they know they won't win
in georgia and they're just hoping that
these mid-sized companies may not
they're not going up their mom and pop
and they're not going after
coca-cola right they're going to go
after individuals that they think have
the ability but to pay but they don't
have the ability to kind of fight it out
right so there's hundreds of thousands
of these lawsuits that are allowed and
all they do is just hurt the bottom line
for people like me who
you know
i don't know how to get around it i
don't know how to advocate i don't know
how to tell people about it because like
you said you know shut down my facebook
account not national news go and sue me
because a blind person says they tried
to go buy something my website um
not a good news story but you know deal
with it and these are the policies that
new york and california are encouraging
and they destroy businesses and to the
point where you know i have another
company called hoist that does military
hydration uh
and they're now telling us that you know
the product is not in compliant with
california's
blah blah blah blah blah standards i'm
not a lawyer right i just have to go get
different lawyers to figure out why i
could sell to everywhere else but
apparently it's california has a
different standard
of uh consumables what is it that you're
selling with hoist
horses military hydration so we sell to
the government for uh and make sure our
troops stay hydrated
imagine
a
drink that i can't say that you were
given when you're really dehydrated you
know as a medical treatment
rhymes with medialite but it tastes
horrible right so it's like that but
tastes good
so we sell it to the government and then
we also sell it to now civilian venues
like publix and walmart and
everywhere else but in california it's
it's getting the same co-packers same
people who make coca-cola products
make this product
but they're not going to go sue
coca-cola they're just going to sue
hoist or companies like me it's because
of like label they want like it to say
may have been created in a lab with they
may have had access to lead
something like that
yes something it's their title 19
california act that just came full force
a couple months ago it's
it's california they're going to find
some other way to mess with business and
then complain that they have no income
tax and that they're bankrupt and they
need a federal government people need to
get out of california i did
i liked it at first i thought i had to
be there because i was an actor so i
thought well it's new yorker la this is
like 2005. and so i in 2006 i moved to
los angeles i was in chicago for a while
too and uh i lived there for seven five
years i got really depressed i didn't
like it it smell the the brake dust i
don't know what but my hypertension was
inten like
was up and i left and then i went back
in 2014 15 because i was like well it's
la i'm going to give it another shot
maybe i'll just but i realize by that
point the internet i mean i'm working
remote i don't need to be in la i was on
the sixth floor and i didn't drive the
second time around which turned into a
whole better experience but still
it was it was dirty chaos man it's uh
you got the the ocean there's there's
benefits to it and you're right ian we
should just move this show to saint
kitts and nevis we should go offshore
uh this show could be done anywhere in
the world i might start working remotely
i mean i love your spot like honestly
this is
middle nowhere this is chicken this is
my jam you got chickens
i i get anxiety when i'm in new york
city when i'm in la when i'm around a
large populated area of mostly angry
people and i understand why you're angry
i used to have to go to school in new
york city it took me three and a half
hours just to get there and then
deal with very angry people who didn't
like my all lives matter shirts except
for isis f those guys like i would wear
it all the time you know it was funny
but it was during the whole blue lives
matter and black lives matter and all
these different lives matter debates and
people just literally would lose their
mind and freak out i'd be walking down
the street with my large female
african-american you know west point
friend and calling her and uncle tom and
telling me mean things and i'm like i
hate new york city i cannot wait to
leave and i get back to savannah
and it's just zen you know everyone is
very nice there's no honking of horns
there's you know it's a it's a different
way of life and the cities are falling
apart man they are yeah it's because of
leadership though because i i'll tell
you new york city
giuliani is a friend uh bernie carrick
the police commissioner in new york city
is a really good friend you know under
their leadership you know
during that 9 11 pre-911 post 911 that
the crime rates the the the just
everything about the city was so much
better
and you change that leadership and you
watch what happens and it is a direct
result
it's not just that it's just like man
i've been really watching
let me jump to this story because this
is important
we have this uh from the guardian
trump sues u.s government over fbi
search of mar-a-lago ex-president seeks
to prevent bureau from reading c's
documents until court official weighs in
well there's the story here's the big
important piece alan dershowitz says
every reputable attorney he's spoken
with has told him their firms won't let
them go anywhere near trump
dude
we can't survive as a country
if this cult keeps expanding and
operating this way this is why i've been
talking about why it's so important to
build culture
and for everybody to start building
industry parallel economies
these lawyers are like i can't i can't
represent trump even though trump's far
from the worst person ever ever
represented in this country
but they can't do it because they're
like oh i'll never get a job again. this
means we need lawyers to make law firms
that are like we don't care if you
represent trump the aclu defended the
clan back in was the 90s i think right
when they were marching through skokie
illinois they defended unite the right
only you know a few years ago and that
was a horrifying moment
now
the cult has expanded to the point where
lawyers aren't working with trump here's
the big here's the big thing trump when
he filed this lawsuit it was pro se
there were no lawyers signed on to it it
was just trump representing himself now
i believe some lawyers have signed on
and the left is mocking him for for it
calling his lawyers like fly-by-night
lawyers and it's like this is a bad
thing
but if you're in the cult and you're
psychotic
it's a good thing you're a communist
everybody has to fall in line and march
in lockstep it's good that no one will
represent your your enemies if we carry
on down that path
i mean you all know where where this
ends up gestapo
i i always joke around like it's step
one control the narrative right and
we've seen it in the history playbook
you know burn the books that are against
your narrative control the media control
the news much easier back in the 40s and
step two you know just i don't need to
take the weapons right now i didn't know
where they are just register
i might need to take certain ones and
eventually i'm going to take all of them
and then after that step three is do
whatever the heck you want there's no
stopping you and i'm not a conspiracy
theorist but i know that i have weapons
that are for hunting and i have weapons
for defending my home and i have sworn
allegiance to
protect and defend this country against
all enemies foreign and domestic and
there are certain inalienable light
rights that i will not give up and you
will have to pry
things out of my hands before you come
to my house and you mess with my
children you come to my you want to jab
them with certain things that you say
are healthy and they're not going to
cause them to have major heart problems
i'm going to say good luck coming to
savannah georgia opening up my door and
sticking something into my children
right that's not going to work out well
so what's um
that's not violence by the way i was
just saying it's the spirit of american
freedom that's the point of it let me
ask you let me ask you a question what's
a um
let's uh what's a 450 bushmaster
round four
are you familiar do you know your guns
i'm not trying to put you on the spot
i'm i'm trying to make up yeah so i i'd
say i have everything from a 50 cal down
to 22s and
every single what's the purpose of a 450
bushmaster let's say let's say polymer
tip 450 bushmaster you tell me at this
point so again i'm not trying to put you
on the spot hunting right big game you
you get maybe like four or five rounds
in the magazine i think so i don't hunt
i'll be clear i like i shoot targets so
right right i'm one of those guys i
don't believe in in killing things uh
except for bad humans so fast so my
point here is uh that's a weapon for for
for hunting animals right sure um what
would you say like uh
bird shot is for you know 20 or 12 gauge
bird shot
birds birds yeah what's a uh barrett m82
a one for 50 bmg humans
banks bad humans helicopters
and uh the thing about that is
you can buy one this is america
and so i've seen these conversations and
it's funny because
what do you think would happen i mean
how do you think the left would respond
i mean they'd lose their minds just
knowing that you would buy such a weapon
they would argue that the fact that
you'd have the conversation about it
would be incitement to violence or
insurrection because there is there's
not a hunting purpose technically for a
50 bmg
it's like an anti-material rifle for
taking out tanks and things like that
yeah well i still have access to 240
bravo machine guns on the side of the
little bird helicopters that fly around
my house and it's georgia again yeah
i've got the undertaking
shooting machine guns and just shooting
targets because it's america you know
because we can and because we're not
bothering anyone and i i don't
i don't understand this uh
concern of the far
whatever the anti-gun that is so
hell-bent on taking them all away when
they've never gone to the countries
where they were taken away where they
currently are taken away you know in
ukraine for example they were all taken
away and they were all handed back out
because
guess who was coming the russians right
know and and you know
they did have guns and they had no guns
apparently
uh zielinski knew they were coming did
you guys see jimmy dore talking about
that today no what yeah apparently
zielinski knew the russians were going
to attack but he didn't tell anybody
because he didn't want to take their
money out of the bank you didn't want to
crash the crash but what everybody knew
was happening there were there was
troops gathered on the border
our president knew that they're right
our president pulled our um elements out
our president could have done a lot more
they could have done a no-fly zone
before there was a war it would not have
been an act of war to declare a no-fly
zone on ukraine by the united states
i'd say our president did the or sorry
not our president somebody during the
afghan evac put a no-fly zone um for
evacuating aircraft right that's weird
state department six aircraft trying to
pull out american hostages what what do
you call it ian that joe biden did in
afghanistan the surrender yes surrender
yes
yeah well anyway i want to go back to
this story a little bit
but basically though our country in
terms of the military um
capabilities and uh you know the
individuals that are out there willing
to do bad things to bad people and they
they are willing to lay down their lives
to do so they wanted to go and rescue
our u.s citizens that were left behind
in afghanistan they wanted to go and
provide aid to the individuals who are
fighting against russians and give them
the capability to defend their own
country at a time of need um but we
actively prevented those things it's not
that we stood by and just watched things
happen we actively put a roz around six
aircraft in mazel sharif when i was
trying to pull people that were american
citizens out of afghanistan right that
that actually happened firsthand
knowledge we
actively
said that the russians are going to take
over this country there's nothing we can
do pull everyone out don't give them any
aid no support world stage the ngos of
the world are the ones that actually
prevented world war iii from occurring
my humble opinion i think the history
books will see it that way too because
now everyone in the brother pours money
which is wasted right all that funds is
squandered waste none of it's going to
where it actually is supposed to go and
i'm boots on the ground there i can tell
you firsthand knowledge i want to jump
back to the story though because the the
the main point that i think we need to
pay attention to is you know within the
past couple of days we're hearing that
donald trump can't get a lawyer then
we're seeing he files a lawsuit pro se
so he's got to try and find somebody to
sign on then the left mocks him over it
this is
man this is this is this is very very
serious in terms of culture war and
leading up to either
we and
look
civil war is is is actually a very
optimistic concept
civil war means
that
there's a chance at preventing
totalitarian takeover because the
reality is you look at weimar germany or
you look at
pre you know communist russia and it was
no civil war it was revolution and
revolution resulted in the nazis and the
soviets
so if in the united states there isn't a
civil war that would just mean these
people have taken over well you could
have a civil war that turns into a
revolution too you got to be careful
about unleashing the beast yeah but
typically what we see with like right in
weimar germany you had the communists
and the fascists they were fighting and
the fascists win but it wasn't like
a civil war necessarily it was political
conflict kind of like what we see here
and so that's that's the thing i think
people need to pay attention to they're
like oh we're not on track for a civil
war we're just seeing political violence
and it's like yeah you're seeing
political violence you're seeing the
weapons weaponization of the dog against
the former president and his
administration you're seeing
him unable to get a lawyer from any firm
and being made fun of for it i'm like
yeah that's kind of like pre-nazi
germany pre-soviet russia level stuff so
okay maybe maybe these people are happy
that there won't be some kind of civil
war and i think
in a certain sense that sounds good
doesn't it no civil war the problem is
what they're actually talking about is
violent revolutionary takeover genocide
murder etc it seems like that we're on
track for globalization somehow that we
have been for probably 20 or 30 years
and that i i was very anti-nationalism
for you know 15 years ago i was like i
screwed the u.s this war in the middle
east because the war in the middle east
was insane like unfounded he lied to get
us and george bush lied to get us in and
killed all these people and destroyed
infrastructure uh i was so fed up with
the nationalist powers being like my
country is better than your country when
it's like dude we're all humans sharing
the planet together let's let's work
together as a species let's create a
language create a currency and move on
it's very naive and then and so a decade
later now i'm looking at how dangerous
globalism can become because the
american experiment is phenomenal
objectively from well i can't be
objective about it but it's pretty cool
most people on earth seem to think it's
pretty cool this sense of freedom that
we have and if the global uh if the
world economic forum and the bank for
international settlements gets to just
dispense with nationalist governments
and create like a corporatocracy we're
screwed that's not good that's that's a
lack of freedom i don't want it but they
keep trying and i think it's inevitable
that we will globalize somehow it's just
anyone that talks about the end of the
liberal international economy
they say that it's ending that anyone is
like
so there's going to be a new
international economy there's going to
be a new world order what's it going to
be like i used to hate the world
economic forum and klaus schwab i don't
even know the guy but now i realize i
want to talk to him because
they want sustainability they don't want
to kill everyone they want to do
something good but like you said earlier
good can be twisted
i don't know if i agree with you ian you
said uh they don't want to kill and ever
kill everybody and i would say
technically correct maybe they don't
want to kind of like i don't want to
have to go and kill all the deer when
their population has expanded too
rapidly right collateral damage you
don't want to kill all the deer because
then they're all gone and they're no the
issue is
you know
what we see from a lot of global elites
when they're saying things like the best
thing you can do for the environment is
not have kids
that's the very nice way of saying they
don't want your family to expand they
don't want you to be here okay so uh
look we know because we have a chicken
city it's stinky because we had too many
so we had to take a bunch of the boys
and send them over to cocktail which is
where all the boys go because when the
chicken boys are around each other they
don't fight but when you put a girl in
there they start fighting so uh way to
separate them and create two different
little chicken towns chicken cities the
smell was getting really bad because the
the the chicken crap couldn't get washed
away fast enough i recognize that as
someone who is literally you know we
have our own chicken coop but we also
know that with deer for instance if
their population isn't kept in check
they start decimating local plant life
and causing
ecological problems so then humans go
out kill a bunch of the bucks get the
population down and under control humans
are not exempt from these concepts now
there are a lot of people who think
overpopulation is a problem that's kind
of the issue there are a lot of people
who think that overpopulation is not a
problem maybe it will be soon either way
these world economic forum people these
global elites they think it is a problem
and if you look at how we deal with uh
invasive species of any other species
why do you think that these global
elites would treat humans any
differently now i will say because
they're humans which is why the approach
is stop having kids
be live in luxury birth control they're
trying to stop human reproduction
because then naturally what happens is
the population slowly dies and then it
it contracts and shrinks down and that's
one way to control population expansion
so my clarification
yeah you're right they don't want to go
around just kill people but they
certainly don't want people to be alive
anymore uncertainty they want
not feces on the streets of new york
they want something there's not so many
people in san francisco that they're
they're clogging the system like what
you're saying about the chicken poop
which is happening in la and in new york
there is a clog right now there's too
many people in a centralized area cities
maybe are are fading away i don't know
the problem is you need electricity to
get from place to place or gas power
maybe that's like that's a luxury maybe
what we got to do is take out a boys
from san francisco and send them to
their own human cocktail where all the
boys can hang out like we do with
chickens i think they'd like that yeah i
don't think it would be a problem so i i
think maybe humans are misappropriated
on earth that we're all stuck in these
mega but then the idea of like creating
mega cities is is a world economic i
think that's an economic forum concept
by 2030 they want mega cities which
doesn't make sense
well it allows you to
control people way way better and the
idea with mega cities is that it keeps
humans away from the environment so
there's less of an impact on external
systems
you know on the ecosystems or
surrounding areas there can be harmony
and you isolate humans certain areas i
actually think the other the opposite is
better i think we'd be better off we'd
be better off with humans spread out
quite a bit more
than we need oh we need to evolve our
postal service this is something i've
been thinking we can evolve the us
postal service into a stratospheric
drone delivery program where we can ship
stuff all over the planet
i think that would be i think what's
going to happen is initiative what's
going to happen is they're going to
increasingly digitize reality like i was
already mentioning earlier in the show
if
if the collapse happened today and the
power went down
we would have the news would be gone
like news archives would be gone you'd
have no way to boot up the internet it
would just be dead servers maybe you got
a solar generator in your house
congratulations you can power your stove
you can power your air conditioning
and you got no access to information
because those data centers are all down
have you backed up wikipedia onto your
phone i'm not saying wikipedia is a
great you know unbiased uh system but
there's a lot of articles on wikipedia
that are like this is what a an edible
flower looks like or something like that
have you downloaded survival guides have
you downloaded encyclopedias in general
put them all on your phone right now
like seriously it's not that hard to do
i think it's like six gigs for the
summation of wikipedia and of course a
lot of the political stuff is very
biased but there's a lot of stuff on
there that's you know might end up
helping you in the long run when you're
like looking up you know drug molecules
or how currents work or something like
that electrical currents
if if the power goes down
you might have power but we lose access
to the grid so here's here's what i
think
i bring that up because it's the
direction we're going in and that's why
i said my idea for a show was people
living in pods living in the metaverse
and never coming outside because they
don't need to the matrix is the it's
seemingly the end conclusion of where
we're all going how do you stop
overpopulation put them in the pods put
them in the matrix how do you stop this
mass pollution humans crapping on the
streets put them in the pods put them in
the matrix how do you deal with with
crime there won't be crime if people are
locked in pods eating bug mash hooked
into their but locking people in pods is
a crime yes against humanity in
they're going to choose to do it they're
going to get neural linked and they're
going to live in some virtual reality
where they're superheroes and they're
not going to care that's so they want to
put people in mega cities and then put
them in the internet so that we're
spread out in the internet i put that in
quotes spread out uh virtually um but
that maybe humans are a virus that are
spreading out of control on the planet
maybe and we've almost eradicated what
what percent of animal wildlife has gone
extinct under our under our watch
90 plus percent of the animals on earth
i don't know about that what's the
number how many what's we're in a mass
extinction of that right now
not everybody agrees oh interesting okay
i've heard that then i've heard that
what'd you say i'm gonna have to google
it okay yes yes hopefully google or the
verb now
uh google the verb so
that argument that humans are uh just an
out-of-control bacterium spreading and
consuming everything on earth i've
thought about that a lot i like to think
that i'm in this individual wondrous
you know
that i should have my own spirit candle
but but these are policies that were
enacted in certain countries like china
where they had population control where
they have people in mega cities that
they can track their whereabouts where
if you want to leave those mega cities
you have to have credit system put in
place like there are this experiment
that you're talking about is going on
right now and it's a direction that i
don't want us to go in and by the way
that when that's specific the bubble is
getting so big it's either about to
burst or it's about to split into two
bubbles and we're going to colonize mars
think about this
so the way social media censors people
the the the the powerful
elites or whatever
politicians would prefer it if we lived
our lives in a metaverse virtual world
as opposed to the real world because the
only thing you can do is what they tell
you you're allowed to do
you say a naughty word
they click a button and then also in
your mouth and the metaverse is gone and
now you can't say naughty words and then
the next generation won't even know
where they just control the individuals
that are out there that you follow i
mean the rock was paid three million
dollars to go talk about uh how much he
loves coveted vaccines and so did a
bunch of other politicians john cena did
that apology in in mandarin remember
that
so we're we're
paying with our tax dollars my my money
that i've worked really hard for that
they've
absolutely just taken at the end of the
year is goes to these high net worth
individuals that don't really need money
that have a massive following you know
sheep that are following them saying hey
don't forgo forget to go get your second
third fourth fifth booster and wear six
masks and you know i do it so you should
do it they don't do it i think they're
getting paid money is what's driving
this in new jersey when uh the lockdown
started there was a woman live streaming
her stores products and the cops came
and shut her down
you couldn't even sell things online it
was not they were it was just
i can only say that was about shutting
down economic activity
and and and what did the new york times
say the earth is healing
so you look at you look at the it's
fascinating because
actions speak louder than words and they
can come out and say they want to do
whatever they want to do i don't care
what these people say
you know i learned this lesson a long
time ago people say they want to do a
lot of things and they don't do them
they'll be like man i really want to go
travel the world i had a buddy and he
was like
man i really want to travel the world
you know like i really want to go to
bali and i was like okay so go and he's
like i can't i was like why not he's
like i can't afford to go to bali dude
and then i pulled up my phone and was
400 for a ticket i was like bro round
trip 400 bucks did you even look i mean
it's like three months out you got to
buy it early and he was like what no and
i'm like you never even looked like
don't come to me and tell me you want to
do something you never even bothered to
google it that's a that's the perfect
example but i had an individual i went
to westbourne with that that hit me up
saying all kinds of critical things
talking about how he would be doing so
much more if he had the
uh opportunities or the the the access
to funding
the privilege right you did and it's hey
you know i would do a lot more with the
charitables up like well actually you
don't know what i do with charity and
i'm involved with this and this and this
and this but i just kind of wanted to go
down that rabbit hole like why why is it
that you can't give back to society why
don't have the money that you don't have
any money you know fine if you have no
money do you have time do you have time
to spare because the individuals that go
and say hey i really wish i could give
back to our homeless population like
there's a thousand different
opportunities to do so just
go do it it's it's individuals that just
want to go and say
i think that someone should fix the
homeless population i would do it if i
could but you know what you know i can't
you can't no you can't you can one at a
time you can you could put an effort
towards making a a a individual
put your time and energy into helping an
individual who wants to be helped you're
never going to help an individual who
doesn't want to be and that's the point
most homeless people don't want to be
helped
i i work with the homeless veterans
that's what our charity does we build
houses for homeless veterans i'm very
tied into that specific but i would say
that you have habitual homeless that are
at they have not hit that rock bottom or
they they find
the overwhelming majority of homeless
people
in you know the shelters that i worked
with refuse shelters refuse to be
involved and have chosen to be homeless
and they won't even take like
the stuff that the the groups i worked
with talked about is like you could go
to them and be like can we just give you
something say get away from me i don't
watch your stuff they would they and and
these these organizations lie i mean
they were there it was also it's also
crooked man that that's the problem when
you have these negative because homeless
individuals they do talk they're not
going to want to go back to the same
place that talks about trying to help
but they don't and wraparound service is
our thing and not like to make this a
long long long story that the
individuals that have hit rock bottom
that do want to get helped if there are
organizations that um you know put their
money where their mouth is you know you
see a change in savannah georgia our
homeless population is is not you know
completely under control but so much
better than other cities and it's
because we have a community where we
have the police the fire the mayor
for-profits non-profits all working
together as a continuum of care saying
hey how can we help
fix this together and we start chipping
how do you eat the elephant one bite at
a time and we've been able to take
massive improvements and we see it every
single year but it's a lot of work and
it's a lot of individuals time money and
effort
but yeah it is much easier to say
it's never going to be fixed i give up
who cares and move on there is a better
system than what's going on in la what's
going on in new york and it does take a
community to come together and make this
initiative not about themselves not
about how do i raise money and look cool
on stage
and then after the charity event i go
back to my normal day and i never go and
deal with one homeless shelter one
homeless person again you know that's
where the authenticity comes in are you
doing the right thing when no one is
paying attention or are you doing it
just for the
social
uh what do they call it virtue signaling
i think a really good example of the
for one i would say first
uh truth is hard to come by
some things are objectively true some
things are hard to break down because
the issues are so complex you can't
possibly see every angle of every story
and so when it comes to to complex
political issues
everybody is saying like this is what's
happening this is what's happening and
they're all looking at a piece but not
the whole and that's the challenge when
it comes something like two plus two
equals four there are people lying
saying duplicate actually five and
they're trying to pass that off with
their weird you know dialectic garbage
it's new math yeah new math but uh but
for most people you can understand a
simple concept like two plus two is four
and y you know but uh for for truth it's
very very difficult when it comes to
doing good things i find that
like uh here's a really good example
i've always heard we want to uh feed the
homeless you ever hear that yeah yeah
people are trying to feed the homeless
and i was always confused by that you
know why
they're homeless they they have they
don't have homes
no one mentioned anything about food in
fact i've seen tons of fat homeless
people so i always i would always hear
this from a lot of the activists that
i'd work with they'd be like we want to
we want to do a food for the homeless
thing and i'll be like are homeless
people hungry and they're like
i don't know and i'm like
don't you shouldn't you home the
homeless and feed the hungry
but there's these ideas that people have
misconceptions i was playing guitar in
the subway in chicago once i had a 300
fiberglass strat acoustic just came out
back in the time this is almost 20 years
ago and this lady comes up to me and she
goes there's a shelter on belmont
do you need a place and i was like lady
i make 40 bucks an hour and she went
what and i was like i have a fiberglass
guitar like i appreciate you're trying
to be nice but like i was like wearing
jeans and a t-shirt and playing music i
wasn't homeless but they don't
understand they don't know people think
they know and i think you know i i uh
this woman was very very nice you know i
was deeply touched that she wanted to
help
but she didn't know what she was talking
about and she made a bunch of
assumptions and thus didn't actually end
up helping anything
i think there's a lot of people who feel
that way like i'd like to to feed the
homeless and i'm like that's really
really awesome
but we need people to actually sit down
and figure out what the problems are and
not just try and
throw pie at the wall because it sounds
like the right thing to do one problem
in california is that there's like a
billion dollar industry to help the
homeless but the thing is they don't
really want to end homelessness because
then the industry is gone joe rogan's
been talking a lot about this he's had
guests on that are talking the experts
in this so they they want to continue to
have homeless people so they keep
getting their billions every year to
keep their jobs like their middle
management jobs and things which is
absolutely i mean
if you ever have to deal with hud and
you have to deal with the bureaucracy
between taking government money to deal
with the homeless then you start
realizing why it's never being fixed
right so if i try to create a program
which we have which is uh how do you
have housing first right not housing
only so i have tiny homes that gets
people off the street gets them put into
an individual house from there they get
taught aquaponics from georgia southern
partnership right with education so they
have a new sense of
pride that they could accomplish
something and then we give them job
placement right so you go from
housing first
then some type of trade craft then an
employment opportunity now you cycle
that person out and you fill that house
with the next person it's a triage right
when i tell people at the triage they
get really mad right especially the the
bleeding heart leftists that have no
intention of actually fixing anything
they just want to tell me how i'm doing
it wrong
so it's hey why are you only taking
these people is it because you're racist
like actually i don't look at anything
other than a specific questionnaire that
has to do with their military records
right but that but that is racist to
them yeah because you're supposed to
discriminate
i guess i'm doing it right
so it's just funny because when you have
people who want to go and tell you how
you're doing it wrong and you ask them
how many times you go on and walk
underneath the bridge and talk to these
individuals how many times have you
actually sat down and said how did you
get here and how can i help you you know
there's so many different situations and
that's where it says like it depends
politics a perfect example with with
homelessness right this it's actually
you know you're giving me an idea we
could solve our security issues and the
swattings by just lining the property
with tiny homes and letting you know and
helping the homeless being like we got a
place for you we're going to teach you
how to use it give them a nice place to
live and then you've got this like
community and then you're just in the
middle and they're you know your
perimeter so you want me to fast forward
to tell you what what actually happened
a couple years later with once the city
got involved with that first project
yeah what did they do they made it so
much better they got rid of all the
things that we were doing that were
successful and made it permanent housing
and they allowed camps all around it and
right before the elections they paid for
everyone to get food and pizza
and told them how
when they help support the new president
coming and getting elected right because
they allowed them to go
you know register all together in
georgia right a huge swaths of homeless
population in atlanta and savannah and
other metropolitan cities you had these
organizers going to these camps and
telling people hey you're homeless
because of
these bad policies not the people who
are trying to help you right now like
we're going to do so much better so
here's how you register just use this
address even though that's illegal but
just use all you guys use this one
address and then yours and then we'll
come back we'll make sure that we take
you guys to go get you know vote
properly and here's some food and here's
a new tent and here's all that they come
out of the woodwork right before weeks
before and then as soon as the
election's over
like a fart in the wind nowhere to be
found
false hope is like blasphemous in my
opinion but yes guess who will be out
there right before the midterms same
group of community organizers telling me
that i'm
a horrible person who doesn't know to
solve this problem but they're going to
come in last minute give some people
some pizza right yep what do they say
give a man a fish feed them for a day
teach them a fish they don't want to
teach you how to fish they don't want to
teach you how to become independent they
have created a new modern slavery where
if you have an individual who is so
dependent on you right i need this
government housing i need this
government credit card for food i need
this government cell phone by the way i
get my real money through cash or some
type of illicit means so i don't declare
income but i'm so dependent on this
awesome group that's given me all this
free stuff that's how i need to vote and
it gets ingrained in their mind that
they have to vote
for the left so they can keep getting
these free things as opposed to vote for
the
organization that wants to empower you
that wants to make it so that you have a
sense of purpose and can generate
revenue on your own and live on your own
who was that guy who said um
something about democracy will end when
when politicians discover they can
simply pay people to vote for them by
you know through the through the
government coffee or something like that
that's exactly right you've heard that
right yeah recently i mean i've heard it
recently yeah he was like once positions
realize they can just bribe the the
population through with their own tax
money then but how are we not doing that
that's literally what's happening well
they're saying like stamps we'll take
the money that everyone's giving us and
then give it to you no i'm going to give
you 500 don't pay attention to 3m i gave
them 3 billion you know don't pay
attention to my other buddy over here at
solarcity i gave them trillions
but i gave you 500 bucks remember that
by the way 500 bucks will buy you two
tanks of gas at this point in time and
that's us too but don't remember don't
forget that we gave you 500.
sorry i'm just going to say that the
system creates dependencies so if you
start to say oh well you know we might
be able to get you off unemployment we
may be able to get you off government
benefits people start to get stressed
because they don't understand what
you'll transition to and that's security
in hand when we built a drop off we
didn't build an escalating scale where
as you make two dollars more we reduce a
dollar of dependency it's i went to give
an employee a 50 cent raise from like 13
13.50 it was a couple years ago and this
person came to me you know this was a
homeless person this was someone that we
took off the street that i just saw
working really hard on the weekends i
work on the weekends
and he told me like hey what are you
saving up for i'm saving up for a house
oh cool where do you live now my car i'm
like holy crap you're a veteran you work
for me like we have to fix these things
but when i went to go give this person a
raise you know it was explained that if
i get this raise i will lose essentially
twenty thousand dollars in benefits you
know i'll lose my my uh ebt card i'll
lose my phone i'll lose all these
different incentives but there's no
elevated scale down right it's once you
hit this marker you lose all of these
things so there's no incentive to make
that extra 50 cents and then an extra 50
cents that extra 50 cents if you were to
have a
i don't know a business person in charge
or someone who actually doesn't want
dependency it would be an elevated scale
you know for every two dollars that
you're making like i said you know we're
going to reduce your your government
assistance by 50 cents you know a
quarter of that so you know i want to
make an extra 50 cents i'm only going to
lose you know 10 cents worth of my
incentives we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and share the share with your
friends head over to timcast.com and
become a member because not only are we
gonna have that members-only uncensored
show coming up at 11 p.m but we have the
first official episode of the cast
castle relaunch is up live now plus
we've got tales from the invited world
so we now have three shows
so we actually technically the green
room is a fourth show so you got the tim
cast uncensored monday through thursday
11 p.m the green room which goes up i
think it goes up at 10 p.m on fridays
we've got cass castle tuesdays at seven
tales from the inverted world sundays at
10 a.m and we're going to keep making
more content we're going to keep
learning and improving let's read some
super chats grafti says ah and and here
we go
watch the cast castle vlog very
entertaining to me you are learning fast
i will get hate and love i only send
love back though stay real
oh forgot buck buck
thank you for the chicken city support
and the support for cascaso vlog
all right
cracker jack says so we're just not
going to talk about the general milli
resignation letter if you don't know
what i'm referring to please check out
angry cops we did talk about the general
milly resignation letter in fact jack
basob a couple weeks ago did this uh uh
he read it while crying right is that
what you did that was funny you see that
he had a very melodramatic reaction yeah
not a big fan
jun wong says tim you say create culture
can you shout out clownfish tv
neon and geeky sparkles been making
comics for 10 years while raising their
kids squin squid king and peeky boo well
all right their passion project crimson
wren is steampunk goonies on an airship
live live on indiegogo this message paid
for by a fan they should use gifsen to
go is an indiegogo like censorious not
as bad as gofundme this guy's been on a
culture of late too who has this guy's
been commenting that on pop culture oh
cool he's excited about it wicked01 says
cass castle was fantastic last week
great job well check out the one that
came up today
because it's quite fun
all right mitch says chris please tell
us three things about yourself
hi i'm chris
that's one thing
uh
i'm uh a youtuber and uh an army vet
what's your youtube channel three things
my youtube channel is reactor
but now he's basically writing cass
castle stuff so yeah
he was fantastic in the blog today i
don't know if i told you that nice work
yeah it's funny you're very funny very
funny very good people keep people keep
changing
all right let's see
strider says tim you mentioned mentioned
a gaming show on your earlier segment
how can i get involved i'm gen z and
would love to work for tim cast i have
no idea i literally don't um
we have jobs at timcast.com but we have
so many emails it's really just a matter
of you know our capacity
and uh managerial power is the most
difficult thing in expanding a company
you want to get a job at tim cast make
something great and make sure tim sees
it do like an awesome video that
highlights your work him looks so
horrified by the suggestions we hired
carter that way yeah
it took six months you're gonna get so
many tweets look for carter banks uh
application slash audition to tim cast
when you see it's easy to hire somebody
if you already know they're great yeah
yeah someone and then i think i remember
people um someone sent it to me like
have you seen this video this dude made
and i was like oh it's really good i was
like i can't hire anybody right now
though and then a few months later
someone was like remember that guy made
that video we need to hire somebody who
can do music and then i was like oh yeah
and then we hit him up and then he was
just like oh wow it took a really long
time but now he's here and the song we
have coming out on friday was produced
and engineered by carter and he's in the
music video singing along and he is so
he's so hard working that's the other
thing about being here you have to be
willing to work he's like a real rock
star
i don't think he considers it work yeah
i think he loves it i think that's the
cool thing about being in this
environment like you get to do things
you're really passionate about yeah
everybody is just basically doing the
things they want to do and i always tell
people like if you don't want to be here
you shouldn't be like nobody should be
here like this is work this sucks
granted there are some jobs that are
basically work like someone has to you
know i don't know take the garbage out
or something see i think like
things can be work and still be good
like you should be feel feeling like
you're being challenged and growing in
the things that you're doing somebody
has to clean up bokus's crap because
he's a little
well
i have disparaging terms for the cat but
you know we love him but uh we try to
let him go and do his business outside
chasing the birds and stuff because he
likes to take dumps on the floor not
okay bokus yeah it's just
graffiti also says only ever wanted
looks and sounds good hey man shout out
within like 12 hours of posting the
promo we have we had like half a million
views on just the promo for the song and
right now we're at like 700 800 000
views oh cool on the promo that's crazy
and i'm kind of like man maybe we should
have just not done a promo because those
views would have been great for the
actual song you know i think the song's
good enough to live on its own yeah the
funny thing is the promo part we put up
is the most like emo sounding part of
the song but the majority of the song is
like literally not like it's very slow
and ambient see i hope it's all emo
stuff only emo stuff from music no the
next one we're putting out um
i don't know if it's a next one we're
putting out but it might actually be
it's like weird experimental
which one of you
oh yeah yeah it's like
people are not gonna i think it's not
mainstream music at all it's weird
can't figure out what the genre is
all right
waffle sensei says tim i know it takes
money but please start making dvds or
flash drives the summation of tim cast
episodes on them history favors the
prepared
should we do season dvds like how many
episodes of this would you be on one dvd
like two
two episodes what one
uh
we'll sell hard drives we'll sell
terabyte hard drives with like
well how many how many episodes you
found that episodes are like two gigs
so a decent amount yeah 500 it's not a
bad idea actually would you do a season
because we don't really do seasons you
just kind of
do your favorite ones yeah i guess you
could technically get every single
episode on like one hard drive
we'll do flash drives with the episodes
on them to start with this one this is
where the idea came from that's right
you have to get it so it's like emp
proof so you can't like
yeah we'll make little little we'll
suspend it inside a small faraday cage
with a small with a bigger faraday cage
over the small faraday cage you can
carry faraday bags faraday yeah
i have a faraday uh
fanny pack that i put my phone in like
you were saying you like to be off grid
that's hot
it's like silver threaded faraday all
right lord crimson i says been to your
location off 204 tyler real nice haven't
visited the red river str uh the the
river street store yet planning to stop
by this weekend
hell yeah cool i gotta say a faraday usb
is a brilliant idea i don't know if
those have been created yet i don't even
know how to spell faraday you'd have to
like
diy
how it would work is the cap see it
would would seal the faraday cage around
the usb you just super glue faraday
cloth around it
but then you need to be able to open it
and close it you know what i mean so if
you had a usb stick that was surrounded
in a faraday cage and you could pop the
cap the top off and stick it in and use
it and close it it'd be protected
but the other thing you need to
understand about the big one the solar
flare everyone always talks about
you don't just need a faraday cage
if you really want to protect stuff you
need a faraday cage with a smaller
faraday cage with a smaller faraday cage
in it because i've been in a really nice
like professional faraday cage
and
emf still leaks through it's not you
know you need a really like
multi-layered really strong one if you
want to stop every signal and create a
real dead zone
faraday is michael faraday's who it's
named after i don't know
scientist did you just google that yeah
yeah i knew he had a name
our new favorite verb
all right
t-craft says get well soon sour patch
that's right lydia has gotten surgery on
her hand and so she's all hopped up on
goofballs so she can't press buttons
because
i think it'd be funny if she did though
she like
is pressing buttons randomly she's on
her the whole show it's just hershey
whatever
still great
i don't use google by the way i use
brave search engine
laramie bryant says reminder everyone
goes out to vote in their runoffs and
primaries and please look into bills
they're
they supported and their track record in
office america first only yeah i think
alaska went to a runoff right
there's gonna be a runoff between the
republican candidates i think it's an
open runoff isn't it well they they're
doing ranked choice so it's they have
four people who are going to the general
and basically everything and then what's
going to happen is the democrats are
going to put all their democrat choices
and then they're going to put at the
bottom of the republican choice of
murkowski because they're like well it's
better than the trump one
and that's how they stop
the trump supporters from getting in
that's how we lost our
senate election in georgia it was ranked
choice we had three with uh we split the
ticket in for the conservative uh
vote and it went to a runoff
good plan
let's grab some more super chats raymond
g stanley jr says history will not be
kind to fouchy there's no way
it depends there is uh
history is written by the winners so it
depends on what happens with all the
politics right now if the republicans
get in and they actually do have
hearings and hold some people
accountable and do investigations yeah
then history won't be kind to him but if
the republicans get in and do nothing
which is seemingly likely or the
democrats end up holding their ground
somehow then uh no fauci will be
you know they'll put up those pictures
of him as jesus or whatever and that's
what will uh will happen
dill 1300 says tyler happy to hear that
you partnered with gulfstream
you sir have a new customer and will
treat myself to new shirts to two new
shirts to celebrate my senior tech promo
here at our appleton wisconsin facility
oh have you have you heard of public
square i have not it is a mobile app
where
it shows you all of the businesses that
support american values it's amazing
what's it called public square i'm
checking that out that's really cool
yeah they uh they're like we'd love to
sponsor the show tim and i'm like yes
and then here i am you can just talk
about it but it's so good it's so
amazing you open it up there's a map and
it shows you all of the businesses that
have basically said like we agree with
these values like the constitution is a
good thing stuff like that like you can
actually just read their values but if a
business is willing to like i stand
behind that message and they appear on
this map they're opening the door
to uh anti-fuck like getting canceled
getting targeted but they're standing
they're standing you know firm on their
beliefs those are the businesses you got
to support yeah definitely so you guys
should definitely they uh
theirs digital businesses can still put
their information in it and then brick
and mortar locations put their brick and
mortar locations then people can see the
pins and then click it and see what
store it is so when and you can type in
what you're looking for clothes food
whatever and then it'll show you in your
city where the american value stores are
at that's what i'm talking about gotta
keep voting with that dollar that's
right stop giving your money to people
who hate you
give your money to uh people who make
clothes in america for instance i'm a
big fan of that like nine line apparel
dot com that that is one
i think there's that's definitely one
for sure that's right i don't know many
others we'll grab some shirts
nuclear drunk 3po says i own a nine-line
shirt and i freaking love it shout out
to drunk3po and i love supporting
american-made
that's the way to do it ian ian called
me out a couple weeks ago about not
buying buying american-made clothes yeah
the banality of evil is sitting by and
just
sucking off the system without you know
we're riding we're riding the beast
that's killing the planet we got to stop
doing that and i'm talking about
supporting slaveocracy basically we got
to stop doing that
yeah i
agree if you you guys ever seen
what those guys are going through it's
not slavery they just they can't leave
they're not paid and bodily harm will
come to them
but it's not slavery whatever that means
yes but your eyes are closed it's
american cotton it's american
manufacturing and everything yeah we
have
optionality right so i've got 10 000
plus raw products that i will then
embellish and we do things in south
america we do things in central america
we do things uh in the united states but
i don't do any business in china and i
don't do any businesses with people or
i guess entities that treat people that
way so i will go and check out the
facilities in peru i'll check out the
facilities you know in in honduras uh
and they're very large reputable humane
compensating people a normal living wage
just like black people goes to their
their coffee farms but starbucks does
not not every thing you sell is
american-made no no we we try to push
american-made everywhere possible but as
you can imagine the cost
for labor cost for everything is much
higher and it's prohibitive for certain
customers where i don't want to lose the
business so i will push as an option hey
here this product this shirt is made 100
in the u.s here's the price point if you
can't hit that price point for whatever
reason your you know big box store or
mom and pop shop and you just can't do
it then here's an option for you it's
made in south america central america um
but without any uh you know slavery a
hundred percent you know i i'm always
going to push u.s but i can't force
people to buy it and that's where
government policies could help me by
giving credits or to stop
the import of those same goods do you
grow your own cotton you guys grow your
own meat personally cotton farmers no we
do not we
work and partner with uh individuals
that do those things my specialty is
mostly uh embellishment and distribution
have you ever looked into vertical farms
to grow cotton indoor yeah that's cool
yeah i mean i i'm really big into
aquaponics uh so we we do aquaponic
center for our
our homeless veterans village you know
it kind of as a therapy but also i think
it's fascinating how fish feed plants
and plants feed fish
and it's completely sustainable and it's
healthier and there's less pesticides
that are used i'm i'm a big fan of being
able to do those things wherever
possible but it's it's not scalable i
mean the facility alone is a million
dollars for a greenhouse about twice the
size
all right let's read some more we got
travis rahman he says can i get a shout
out to my stepdaughter zoey who's 16
today shout out zoe happy birthday i'm
zoe also my son connor and step daughter
jaden turning 12 friday oh wow both of
them are turning 12 months for birthdays
you guys that's awesome sounds like just
one big connor and jaden both having a
birthday on friday nice that's that's
perfect timing to listen to the release
of our new song only ever wanted you can
they can play it on their birthday party
happy 12th birthday
here's a song you gotta listen to like i
don't like this music it's for old
people
it's funny because um
there are people who are like trying to
rag on the song and they're like oh the
2000's called they want their music back
and i'm like the 2000s are so trendy
right now like right back i just like
dude look
is is like the idea here that we're
supposed to make katy perry music
or do we just make music that we like
and understand that like i'm not trying
to be katy perry you know what i mean
like if i wanted a top 40 i'd do like a
rap song you know like post malone style
or something one i think what we've lost
is vocal harmonies having two or more
people vocally harmonizing on a song
together what if maybe that's 70s maybe
the 70s are back but what if we like
took the guitar out i just added more
vocals and then took out the drums and
had a guy make the drum sounds with his
mouth with his mouth and then did a
couple more vocals and just you know and
then we could hire pentatonix to play
the instruments for us yeah they're
actually playing the instruments
all right dalamar says spent hundreds
with you quality stuff and i clicked
that made in america button when it pops
bring back the share around with antifa
shirt for a limited time more people ask
where i got it than even the
mando design
i made it i made a gag shirt
that said liberals get the bike lock too
it was a gag reference to
antifa wrote liberals get the bullet too
on a wall and so i was basically mocking
them because this antivir guy hits them
with a bike lock and they got really mad
at me
the the big companies were like youtube
banned the shirt and they were all i'd
coca-cola try to sue me for my share
around with isis cheryl like it's it's
just comical yeah you know it's
what is get over it what did it say it's
a it's a
similar looking to coca-cola
not their logos or designs i'm not
admitting to anything but very similar
um
and it says share a round and it's got a
bullet
with
oh okay
see it's like play on words comical
but people take things very seriously so
the social media oligarchs said that
that was inciting violence right so
that's what happened i wouldn't happily
sell it i just can't
promote it or post it anywhere what if
the intent was like to make sure you're
sharing ammo with people who want to go
have target practice my intent was to
actually share around with an isis
terrorist so to to kill them so that was
my intent i guess they they were correct
well here here here's the i want to
share around here
here's a challenge with that we're we're
actively at war with these people yes
well they're at war with us we're right
in the sand yeah but but i mean when you
look at like russia and ukraine and
stuff facebook said calls for violence
against russia was acceptable so i
wonder if like why is it that facebook
was like okay if you're calling for
violence against russians because of the
war that's fine but why would they say
no to the isis thing like for i'll say
this like we don't want to call for
violence but
where is the line when your country is
actively at war with like an invading or
terroristic force and we're telling you
to like save people or if you're a
multinational
company
which one did you choose to go with is
it right after russia banned you
in your entire platform then you became
virtuous because that's when it occurred
because i was physically over there
but i will tell you that they could care
less as long as they're making money
that's really what it boils with the
with the shirt that i made it was meant
to be in it was like opposing the
violence it was it was to make fun of
them and to deride them because it's
like it's crazy but i don't understand
why people are like that doesn't sound
like what it's i'm like yeah okay i get
there yeah no man mine was pretty to the
point like you there you you can
probably shape the minds of a young
kid who's being taught terroristic ways
but by the time they're in their 20s and
30s and 40s and they've committed acts
and they're they're committed to being a
terrorist
there's there's not much you can do but
i think the distinction there is
the distinction there is we're not
talking about like walking up some
random person we're talking about
people whose lives are actively under
attack by a group that's shooting at
them and blowing them up and we're
talking about pure evil you're talking
about individuals who are setting other
individuals on fire we're talking about
joe biden who drone strike with the
shredder the taliban guy so that it's an
interesting point because you know
youtube's got their youtube facebook and
twitter have their violence policies but
it's like what if you're what if you're
cheering for joe biden who fired that
shredder missile at a terrorist right
like where you know i'm also thinking
about like the military they say that
the the enlistment numbers are down and
it's like there's a bit of a hunter
go kill the thing mentality for someone
that wants to join a military and maybe
we've lost that or i i just
i just want to say you know what man
like i wish
none of this happened i wish you know
you you were mentioning how when you
were younger you were like we're all
just people can't we get along and like
i wish that was the case i wish i wish
isis would stop doing these things i
wish the ideology didn't exist i wish
there wasn't war but right now you've
got like russia for instance they invade
ukraine like what are we supposed to say
to that are we supposed to be you know
look i don't i don't like american
intervention i don't like the u.s you
know all that stuff but am i supposed to
be like no no ukrainians should just let
them do it it's like nope there's
there's good and evil in the world my
grandfather
entered world war ii at the age of 17
stormed the beaches of iwo jima got shot
in the knee got shot in the helmet but
he set that example of that's not my
fight but me and all my friends are
going to
fake our age we're going to go and stop
pure evil and that i will tell you that
that the things that they're doing to
the ukrainian people is pure evil that's
it's it's
what
hitler and his band of merry horrible
humans did to the jewish population and
it's
it's
unfathomable that we would do nothing
let's read some more super chats augusto
mimoshay says tyler stephen crowder has
been looking for an american company to
make his hand-painted mugs for mug club
members can you help him louder with
crowder yes we've talked to him a bunch
of times about doing their shirts and
everything else i just think
their merchandising manager needs to
pull the trigger and give us a call
right on
sell some mugs we made gag mugs that
said uh louder with roberto bug club
because our rooster was always yelling
did you make the joke somewhere no but i
used it as a prop today that was awesome
we make our mugs here in the u.s and uh
do it for us and i know black rife will
make some usa made mugs so i'm sure
louder with crowder could too
ryan the eating warrior says you guys
need to watch the video the five laws of
stupidity it explains that stupid people
are the most dangerous demographic and
man is it true
yes
but you know
we all want to get along we want to find
out you know we want to figure out a way
that we can live peacefully in this
country we don't want fighting we don't
want violence but um what do you do when
you have like antifa going around
smashing up windows communication is a
big part of it you got to keep people
calm we need like i think that the
monarchy basically started to fall apart
when at the event of the printing press
people didn't need to funnel their
information through a centralized figure
so the more ability we have with
language to communicate um understanding
similar definitions and where our
definitions are coming from
actual radio things like that also like
yeah some people might be dangerous but
like what's your plan for them you know
there are drone delivery we need to be
able to send food to people that are in
remote areas but if you have more of the
question no i was just going to say like
you can
offer people all kinds of opportunity to
better themselves and learn but there
are some people who aren't motivated by
that like yes it's good to advocate for
peace but also let's be realistic and
think about how we can incorporate a
society that has
uh a variety of options for people that
don't involve pushing everyone like what
bothers me about people saying stuff
like that is like okay cool but
why do we push everyone to follow the
same educational structure why do we
have the exact same model for public
schools like that consistently fails
students we're saying that stupid people
are the problem but we're not using any
innovation to try and change it's
cultural it's really every everything is
culture everything is parents raising
their kids we talk about changing laws
we talk about all of these things
culture it's a degradation of values
they say you're a product of your
environment and it's really hard for
individuals to break out of
that negative environment right so if my
kids have opportunities that i've never
had you know that they
good schools where they're not getting
beat up all the time where they're not
the minority where they're not you know
having to um you know go through those
adversities but those adversities make
make you who you are they've definitely
defined you sean willis says tim you say
50 bmg has no self-defense or hunting
purpose i didn't say that
well uh what i said what i was saying
was that it's for it's an anti-material
round it's for tanks and helicopters and
certainly the ukrainians would consider
that defense right now if like they're
fighting a russian helicopter you know
uh or hunting purpose and for the most
part i don't know if you need a 50 bmg
for any kind of game but anyway sorry
sean let me read your comment he says
well i'm not going to be caught in the
woods with my pants down when a 10 foot
tall bigfoot doesn't like the cut of my
jib no sir
here's i'll put it this way
uh a a a barrett m82 a1
you're not going to be carrying that
around and then like encounter a bigfoot
and then be like i'm going to defend
myself what you're going to do is you're
going to have it mounted in various
points around your your wood your your
um rural fortress and when the army of
big foots or the big feet uh i think i
think both will work yeah i think big
feet when the big female big foot big
thing is
when the big bigfoots
when when the big big beats big feet is
the way when the big feet show up and
they're banging on the sides and they're
trying to punch their way in and they're
all 10 to 15 tall and they're eating
humans and they're mindless uh then you
might need it you know then you might
need the uh
i'm a big advocate of drawing them to
the base to let base defenses take care
of them in video games when i that's
good somebody's uh i don't know where
super chat went but they said that my tv
show idea sounded like dr stone
which it does not at all it's more like
attack on titan not like dr stone dr
stone's cool dr stone uh people get
turned to stone and then you know
thousands of years later this smart kid
figured out a way to unstone himself
and then he has to rebuild technology
from scratch and it's actually really
interesting so it's like an anime where
he's like i'm gonna make a cell phone
and then he's like collecting materials
to make a vacuum tube and stuff and it's
like
it's like magic school bus but kind of
cool cool video game if you actually
taught the specifics of how to build
micro economic electronics and economics
with both maybe
all right what is this uh oh i just had
a good one where'd it go
there we go there we go what is this
ready to rumble says ian did you see the
news about jwt proving universe didn't
start with the big bang poor einstein
i saw that that was interesting no
what's that story i don't know if it's
definitively proven because i haven't
read it but what they're saying is the
james webb telescope should be showing
us that um due to an illusion with the
expansion of the universe galaxies
further away should start to appear
larger because of the way the light is
moving towards us but the universe is
expanding at the same time instead they
look smaller which would either indicate
based on big bang theory that they're
tiny tiny galaxies
or
there's not a universal expansion yeah i
don't think there is a universal
expansion i think it's twisting around
on itself like a double helix
um or a double taurus really more
accurately so maybe we could integrate
that into the theory the hypothesis
smoking says
just watched episode one i'm assuming of
cast castle you are a master of lowering
expectations i enjoyed it didn't think i
would expect it hack it's not carry on
button well it's a masterpiece obviously
i'm just saying like we we just have
some dslr dslrs we filmed funny things
with mostly what you know chris was
putting together and um
we need to improve lighting we need to
get better microphones and just set it
up but we just wanted to start making
stuff because it's fun we did a bunch of
really funny bits with uh with jamie
kilstein with with sheamus you know
previously and uh
it was really really fun to do so i was
like how can we do that consistently and
then here's the best part
from the first from the promo episode we
had this the sketch with jack bosobic
riding up on a little bike with a wagon
delivering the scripts for tim cast as
if it was scripted and he's like got him
out of mar-a-lago just in time and then
he's like ringing with a little bike and
then he runs it got over a hundred
thousand views just this one gag
so the idea here was
what really works on youtube is that we
have these funny bits but it's not easy
to share when it's a full 20 minute or
10 minute video so we are like can we
just take the funny things we do with
our friends and guests and then make
those really shareable videos that are
just basically promos for the full show
so uh i don't want to spoil anything but
marjorie taylor green did a bit with us
and it was really really good it's
really good and uh ian's in it
and uh we're gonna have that up i think
that one's me next week and then we're
excited well i don't want to say anymore
because we have upcoming guests we
normally don't announce who the guests
are so i won't say much but we'll grab
just a couple more super chats maybe
just one more super chat
chris
scana uh piso i'm probably not in that
wrong nine line is that a reference to a
military nine line do you guys sell a
good dry fit shirt
we do and yes it is so nine line's a
casualty call in the military we like to
say back here it's a call for action to
try to reinvigorate patriotism right on
what does that mean nine line i haven't
heard that term before so not in the
military nine line is a casualty call so
nine separate radio communications that
go to someone like me who's a kazovac uh
pilot and i would come into the
battlefield and pull you off and get you
to safety and call it the golden hour so
if you're bleeding out trying to get you
to a hospital or some type of surgical
bed within that first hour of trauma
they call it nine line because they
actually call you nine times is that
what you said no so it's it's one radio
call with nine separate lines of
information i need like where the bad
guys are where the good guys are what
are you marking the landing zone with
what type of litter do you need me to
bring is there the last one is nuclear
biological and chemical considerations
which if you're telling me things on
line nine that sucks uh that means i'm
wearing a mop suit and it's really hot
and
i haven't had one of those but uh yeah
it's it's just saying that i'm injured
come get me uh and most likely under
under fire
and that's why most people in the
military know what a nine line is it's
it's a call for help and like i said try
to make that transition here it's a call
for action right on ladies and gentlemen
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button right now share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com because we're gonna have
a spicy members only show coming up and
they've been particularly spicy over the
past couple of weeks and increasingly
spicier but that's the way that's the
way the news is right now and there's a
lot of crazy stuff happening we're gonna
talk i think about um monkey pox so you
know where that's going so yeah head
over to timcast.com you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally at tim cast you can check out
timcast records on youtube we have the
promo up for the song coming out on
friday and uh uh tyler you want to shout
anything out uh yeah check out all the
things he said and uh check out
ninelineapril.com right on it's
shameless plug
i'm here claire brimlo i write for
timcast.com i think you should check it
every day for all of your news uh you
can find me on instagram at hannah
claire.b and you can follow me anywhere
on the internet at ian crossland for the
most part make sure it's me because
there are some ian crosslands out there
there are other ian crossovers out there
other than me but you know where to find
me see you guys later and you can follow
me on social media
we're actually uh with with the launch
of tim cast records we're going to be
producing music for other bands we're
probably going to be signing deals with
other bands to start producing more
music across the board and then we're
going to start making music so um
i don't exactly know how we're going to
start scouting out bands and doing deals
but we are and we've already got a bunch
of people hitting us up they're like oh
sign me send me and i'm like yeah i
guess we'll figure it out uh it's like
do you have good music and
that's the big question so with that
being said we will see all of you over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
you